We're seeing something very interesting happening
over the last 24 to 48 hours in the United
States.
On the one hand, you have Donald Trump and
the administration and even many Republicans
insisting everything must open, Disneyworld
must open, schools must open.
And of course, it doesn't really make sense,
because if schools had to close when we had
100000 active cases, it's not really following
that.
It would be safe to then open the schools
when we have two million active cases or close
to it.
But what's very interesting is that the country,
fortunately seems to be leaning in the direction
of reality and scaling back plans to open
rather than following the obvious lies of
Donald Trump and opening more and more.
And why would they follow Donald Trump over
the last 48 hours?
The Trump White House has released a list
of things.
Dr. Anthony Fauci.
She got wrong while Donald Trump was retweeting
the conspiracy theories of former game show
host Chuck Woolery.
Governors and also many mayors, however, have
to deal with the day to day of increasingly
full icy use, increasing hospitalization rates.
The mayor of Houston, Texas, Sylvester Turner,
who's a Democrat, is proposing a strict two
week shut down.
Even the Republican governor in Texas, Greg
Abbott, is talking about stricter gap guidelines.
They've put in a mandatory mask order in California.
Over the last two days, we've seen the Democratic
governor, Gavin Newsom, say indoor restaurants
have to close again, closed wineries, closed
movie theaters, closed zoos, museums, certainly
bars must close.
A Los Angeles and San Diego are saying we're
not opening schools.
The fall semester, the fall, the school year
in the fall is going to start online.
Only Oregon has said once again, no gatherings
of more than 10 people.
Kentucky Fried Chicken or I guess now it's
just called KFC.
They are telling franchises in a lot of these
states.
You've got to stop indoor dining.
And this makes sense.
And even the economic arguments fall short
because the short term benefit of opening
things too quickly is going to backfire.
It's going to evaporate and you're going to
end up with a much worse economic situation
if you have a big relapse effect.
And in the end, the long term results are
going to be based on flattening the curve
in a serious manner.
But that's not this administration's priority.
Trump's priority is getting reelected in November.
That's his gambit.
His idea is anything I can do in the next
three and a half months that will make it
seem as though life is returning to normal,
will benefit me politically.
And that is the only thing that he cares about
now.
Unfortunately, the timing hasn't worked out
because instead of a nice gap now leading
into the election with few cases and few deaths,
we're seeing a massive resurgence, which shouldn't
surprise us because when we got down to 20000
cases a day, states went crazy reopening.
And now we're seeing that resurgence.
Now, I'm going to be totally upfront with
you guys about something, because this came
up on the bonus show yesterday, sort of briefly.
And people wrote to me and they said, David,
I want to hear more about this.
I know some people may be mad because not
everybody's in a position to be able to do
this because they have different types of
jobs.
Things are potentially going to get so bad
here in the United States and it's even going
to bleed into Massachusetts.
I am seriously looking at finding it.
Is it possible I could do the show from somewhere
else in the fall where I could get a break
from what's going on in the United States
and just be somewhere else?
And by that I mean another country.
Now, of course, the problem is Americans are
banned from much of the world right now because
it's so bad here.
So I've not looked into it in a huge amount
of detail.
But would it be possible to put the mask on?
Take a corona virus test, quarantine 14 days.
And if I'm gonna be, you know, just buckling
in and writing it out for three or four months,
maybe that is something I would actually be
interested in doing, because the reality is
what it increasingly looks like is the best
case.
Best case.
It takes two months for a lockdown to have
a big impact.
We saw it in New York, Texas, Florida, you
know, etc. lockdown today.
We're looking at large case numbers at least
until mid-September.
They don't look like they want to do full
lockdown.
So we could be looking at this going well
into the fall if Joe Biden wins in November.
And we get the most optimistic timeline with
an early youth vaccine for health care workers
at that point in time.
Optimistically, things aren't going to really
dramatically improve until early 2021.
That that's just an unfortunate reality.
Joe Biden will hopefully take over then treatments
and vaccinations will hopefully start to become
a reality in the short term.
Hopefully, we see governors and mayors do
the right thing.
But when you're seeing five, seven, ten, fifteen
thousand cases a day in some states like we're
seeing right now, the best cases, you need
months to come down from numbers that high.
And I understand that I'm truly privileged
to live in Massachusetts.
I can't imagine what my friends in Florida,
Arizona, California, Texas are going through
right now.
And it's going to remain incredibly ugly for
a long time.
If there's any good news, it's that some governors
and mayors seem to be taking this seriously.
Let me know what's going on in your city or
state.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember to get the daily audio podcast
on Spotify, Stitcher, Eichmanns, Google Play,
wherever you prefer to listen to your podcasts.